new york governor andrew cuomo expecting
lots of nice presents under his tree
this year
take a look healthy holiday
and i'm going to have a great one
santa's going to be very good to me
i can tell i worked hard this year
you know i think many would disagree
here's a whole bunch of reasons why
the love gov shouldn't get nothing but
coal
you want to go to work go take the job
as an essential worker
do it tomorrow by the state's numbers
you hit 3 percent the schools
close how what are you talking about
you're now going to override we did it
already
that's the law an orange zone in a red
zone
follow the facts still confused but then
you're confused
you know i i think that any time you pat
yourself on the back and i tell my kids
this all the time
you don't tell me you've been good for
christmas i
tell you uh and then ultimately santa
will make his decision i i think it's
kind of selfish
given some of the circumstances what
happened that he would be that jovial
and that excited about himself water's
your i know
evil waters ain't taking that mess at
all your thoughts on someone telling you
they've been good this year
i've never seen anybody besides me of
course
that makes everything about himself the
way
governor malmo does um honestly
geraldo you're third geraldo i am in awe
of this man's ego and i'm dead
serious i am literally in awe i mean
governor cuomo my goodness
you basically were blindsided by this
pandemic
you botched it and then you clocked in
with the highest death toll
then you wrote a book about how great
you did and right after the book comes
out we get hit with the second wave and
he thinks santa
is coming to the governor's mansion
first it's that type of delusional
arrogance that actually makes him a
really potent politician
you know uh the fact that you mentioned
the great
geraldo rivera and it's an honor to be
on the stage for the first time sir
i will allow you to defend yourself how
how dare waters
you know the cuomo family i i
have been relatively close to them chris
cuomo
now on cnn was my protege i put him in
the
put him on television really his dad
mario the three-time governor was a
frequent guest on my show thanks a lot
you know his mom matilda is a saint
matilda matilda's a saint she's really a
wonderful person but
uh andrew never got that that uh gene
that that schmoozy
nice guy gene he's he's arrogant uh he
can be a bully as you saw there
uh you know i think that he lost it when
dana and i were talking about this
earlier today when the ventilators
didn't come or he
started running out in new york he kind
of panicked uh
and the whole nursing home thing with
the with the genestein's
in-laws you know there's a lot of things
that he did that really really screwed
up but new yorkers still
he's still 56 percent so uh he's he's
doing and he's running for a fourth term
so uh maybe he does get uh santa does
cut him some slack
kate does he is it ever okay for a
politician to tell you how great he is
uh not if you've screwed up everything
along the way i mean
it's it's i hate to be like this isn't
the funny person but it's really not
when you have people like janice dean
who lost
two of her husband's parents uh
basically at the same time because of a
policy decision that
andrew cuomo made early on that he's
never accounted for
he's never explained why they made that
decision and why it was the right one
and there are a lot of families in new
york for christmas this week who aren't
going to have that person sitting at
their table
and maybe that could have been prevented
as some different decisions were made
now
you know it's easy to monday morning
quarterback but he's
his attitude towards the things that
have happened is not one of learning
from mistakes or
being empathetic or sympathetic for the
decisions that he's made
and there's a lot of people who are out
of work in restaurants too or who can't
afford to buy their kids christmas
presents
or have santa coming so you know that's
the situation
dana i think it's safe that you have
never received coal in your entire life
can you is there any advice you could
give uh cuomo to how to better carry
himself
to where we don't all get insulted i'm
just trying to figure out
i'm just trying to figure out how to
have a bigger ego i think it might
really help me
um if anybody has any tips on that i
will talk to you about
confidence yes don't you change dana
don't you ever change
i think that santa would be reluctant to
try to give
cuomo a lump of coal because he would
get arrested by the new climate czar
john kerry that's true that's how you
take it home